this is Liam Neeson returning as a
badass for takin - there's no way this
can screw up there's no way can suck
right it's just awakened suck take in -
so when taken to the family members of
the guys that Liam Neeson took out and
taken one they're pretty pissed at him
cuz he wiped out a lot of guys and taken
one so Boris the blade over there it's
like alright you know what we're gonna
get our revenge
so they embark on the revenge scheme to
take famke janssen his daughter and him
that's right everyone's supposed to get
taken in this movie is that a good thing
no no it's not first of all the build-up
in this movie you're like alright a lot
of family time let's you know let's get
to the killing and then Liam Neeson and
his ex-wife get captured they get taken
away missions just chained up he's not
doing anything alright let's go back to
taking one Lee Mason was like I don't
know who you are but I'm a complete
badass if you give my daughter back I'll
let you go otherwise I'm going to rain
hell on you dude tells him good luck
didn't Liam Neeson does everything he
promised to do he's a one-man army and
he goes in there to get his daughter
back it's really cool see and Liam
Neeson be on the offense if you know
he's following the trail of where his
daughter was where she was taken he's
tracking guy is down he's wiping dudes
out it was a good movie and when this
movie he spends the first part of it
chained up in which case he's coaching
Maggie Grace how not to be a badass but
how to be capable what come on the bad
guys do stupid things like Boris the
blade comes in Nick's famke Jensen's
neck just a little bit hangs her upside
down to his light you have 30 minutes
until she bleeds to death and then he
leaves
alright you pretty much told God in
human form the guy who took out about
five hundred are your guys in the first
movie he has a 30-minute time limit to
get out of his restraints and then you
left him alone you're the dumbest
criminal on the face of the planet
then the movie just goes all over the
place and Liam Neeson you know and he
picks up the gun he starts to be a
badass and Liam Neeson goes to try to
save the day all the while any time
someone gets into a fight it's that
really not just shaky cam but it's
close-quarters shaky cam the cameras
like zoomed into their chests and shakin
around like this you don't see what's
happening so many times I was like that
dude died is he dead couple of times I'm
pretty sure Liam Neeson did nothing but
do a Vulcan death grip on a person's
face and they just died I think
apparently when Liam Neeson's hand
touches your face your soul just goes
yet your
right piece I'm at problem is this movie
forgot what taken was taking was a
pretty simple premise but it was really
entertaining one dude on a badass
mission to get his daughter back from
these people who sell kids into sex
slavery this movie tried to incorporate
the family too much like they were
important for the plot like there were
anything other than the damsels in
distress this movie felt like it was
just trucking through mud this is the
epitome of a cash crab the first movie
works really well people loved it so
they're like a taking twos gonna happen
so let's write a really forced movie
with really dumb criminals and try to
make it more than what it should be
which makes the movie come off as
convoluted and just messy as this
was like the kind of movie you watch and
you say to yourself you're like oh that
was a movie that was just trying to rip
off taking all the things it didn't
succeed problem is this has all the
actors from the movie taken so what do
you do you call it taken - I guess I
will say with taken - you're not gonna
remember in t-minus two hours yep
already forgot I just know sometimes
when I watch a movie I think to myself
that would be okay if I were drunk this
was not one of those movies it was a
movie that I started forgetting about as
I was driving home from the theater
right so your favorite revenge flick
best revenge movie of all time for you
what is it comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more